the next 10 minutes of this video are
going to be so important to listen to
because it's a very strategic time on
YouTube right now and I have some tips
for you right up front but this is the
coffee with canel show so we have two
guests today we're going to be doing
some Q&A and coaching check out time
codes and chapters to skip around in it
we're going to be doing Q&A coaching
with two individuals answering your
questions talking about YouTube strategy
getting ready for 2024 how can we get
views how can we get subscribers but
right off the top and uh I want to
mention today's episode's brought to you
by
think media sale.com more on that later
as well as vid iq.com think more on that
later but right off the top it's a
strategic time happy December 1st I hope
your November went good Happy
Thanksgiving wherever you are in the
world whatever you celebrate it's a
great time to be grateful but I want to
encourage you this is such a strategic
time on YouTube right now and there's a
major Temptation in PLL right now a lot
of people probably 95% actually start to
kind of check out I mean it's December
it's holiday parties it's been a crazy
year there's so much drama in the world
and everything that's happening man I
just kind of want to hide away maybe
rewatch The Office maybe get a little
bit of Ben and Jerry's maybe just kind
of watch elfl and jump on Disney plus
and go through the Christmas movie
rabbit hole all of that's cool but
there's such an opportunity right now to
really go all in on YouTube and one of
the things to understand about YouTube
is the seasons and the times and The
rhythms as it pertains to views and
really as it pertains to money to be
made on the platform so let me
illustrate it this way November December
and January so really the next 60 days
are the most profitable times to be on
YouTube and I can prove it to you so let
me take you behind the scenes and share
with you um the analytics from Channel
think media and share how much money
that we make now of course this is all
relative and we have you know a larger
Channel but I want to share with you how
much money we earned last year and talk
about how strategic right now is okay so
if we go to how much money we earned on
my channel think media okay and what
we're looking at too is less about the
dollar amount but let's go back and what
we could see is actually January of last
year and December of last year and then
I think we scroll down we got June
January December here's here's my point
look over on the far right side and
actually this is kind of good to know I
was reviewing this with some of our team
and sometimes we don't dive deep into
our analytics but what we can look at is
not only do you go to your analytics you
go to revenue but then you want to go to
the how much you're earning see more and
now you're in an advanced analytics and
what you're going to be comparing here
is you have the opportunity to not just
see what your estimated Revenue was um
but you also get to see your
CPM and your CPM again is the amount of
money advertisers are willing to pay for
um on your videos now cpms vary and so
this is going to be different if you
have you know viral reuploads of Tik
toks and Cat videos versus personal
finance versus uh DIY videos they vary
but what happens in November December
and January is advertisers ad spend goes
up which means your Revenue
go your Revenue goes up if your CH
channel is monetized okay so what does
that mean it means that strategically
the more content you can post and the
more views you could get the more money
you can make and in a way not because
you're doing anything different but
because the envirment is different it's
the season where cpms are higher and so
what I can actually see here is that in
January and December we're at 2179 and
2183 uh November was
2236 and so that was some Peaks if you
will and then uh I mean it all kind of
hovers throughout the year around there
at least for us this is our experience
but then if I look at my ad Revenue now
January last year 50 Grand uh that was I
think the peak of the Year lowest being
like 32 and there's the other reason of
it's not just your CPM and your RPM
which let me know what yours is you
could drop it in the comments have you
noticed is different or maybe your
experience is different as does it
actually go down right now I'm not sure
but as a rule advertisers they're trying
to do all their holiday sales they're
getting their messaging out there okay
the other thing that's happening is
there strategic times a year depending
on your type of content people are
hanging out at home more they're may be
watching it more like what we've noticed
is not just November and December is
holiday shopping we talk about tech and
so this is a very strategic time to do
camera reviews or really or video
reviews we do camera reviews it's a
strategic time to do like product
reviews what product could you review in
the next couple weeks what product
comparison could you review in the next
couple weeks what video could you do
that's a tutorial about a product in the
next couple weeks connected to affiliate
marketing right strategic time but the
other thing is you just want to think
about psychology and mindset so what
happens for us in in January is
everyone's like okay new year new me
it's time to start my channel it's time
to get focused on my channel it's time
to spend my gift card and buy that
camera on Amazon because I'm going to do
YouTube this year and so the spike is
also just based on January has a lot of
momentum because of people's mindset and
what's so important for us is to think
strategically about our entire year like
you want to be hustling when when people
are paying attention but there's other
times when people are may be more
checked out call it summer so rhythms
for different channels can be different
but my challenge to you wishing you a
happy December 1st
2023 is how can you make strategic
videos right now that position you to
maximize December but also to prepare
for January and I'm not saying like you
shouldn't be definitely resting and
recovering and family that's one of our
biggest values family is everything but
we're plan the the people who have the
best results they're they don't start
planning and New Year's resolutions on
January 1 they start planning December
1st if not earlier they're more
strategic a month ahead two months ahead
of everybody else and 99% of people are
like I'm just gonna check out until next
year man I'll maybe get serious on
January 1st don't get serious on January
1 get serious right now so let me know
what are some of your goals what do you
focusing on where are you watching from
uh what are you up to as far as this
month what videos are you going to post
this month and did that bring any aha
moments maybe let me know is there a
video that you could make or review
because now's a time when a lot of
people are shopping you know one of our
favorite product review videos final tip
is called the versus video and you don't
have to be a tech channel to uh to do a
versus video let me actually give you
kind of a cool idea here like uh I've
been drinking these electrolytes you
ever heard of limit electrolytes they're
full of salt I'm probably going to die
and so ele uh element electrolytes but
watch this element electrolytes versus
liquid IV element electrolytes
versus relight maybe go element versus
relight because I heard about this
relight one which also doesn't have a
th000 milligrams of sodium it only has
700 or 600 so element versus relight
here you go we got a video right up here
to years ago 5K views keto drink
comparison to me I mean it's only a one
minute video could probably be a little
bit longer look at nestia here got
47,000 views worth the hype this guy's
got 22,000 views that's almost that's
double his subscribers why well people
don't know this Creator yet they know
they're searching for a review of this
electroly powder you know you can go to
Amazon and get an Amazon link for that
powder I wonder if you can go to
element's website thems and if they have
an affiliate program I haven't checked
let's go look and so we got uh we top
type in element element affiliate uh
click the
link and this is a let's see if we get
is this the partner program it says
partner program right here so uh
partners. drink element.com I don't know
why I call it elementy it's element
apply to be a wholesale partner okay so
here's a partner I don't know if if we
would be that's wholesale so okay maybe
you can't be an affiliate here you can
be an affiliate on Amazon maybe another
website and that's just me spontaneously
thinking about like if you had a health
Channel or something that there's some
strategic videos you could do one of my
favorites is the versus video comparing
two products people are searching this
month and what are they gonna do in
January oh man I got to get my hydration
right I gotta get my energy right I'm
gonna get my vitamins right I'm gonna
get my workout program I'm going to get
my fashion right I'm get my YouTube
channel right what's the mindset I hope
this is helpful for you to be a little
bit more strategic as you prepare for
next year okay um I'm not sure if we're
going to bring our guests into the
waiting room we could do that uh if we
are not I want to welcome you to the
coffee with candle show what are you
drinking where are you watching from
I've got uh as I would I don't know what
this is it's some black and white
Ethiopia jurash Chef coffee just brewed
my second cup that's May and do I need
it I I showed up to the stream a little
bit fired up but uh we're going to get
crushing here Jason and Alex are going
to be on in just a bit but as you know
smash the like button because this is
the coffee with C
[Music]
shell welcome back to coffee with canel
my name is Sean canel rhymes with
YouTube channel this this is the show
where I answer your questions where we
do live coaching with YouTube creators
and entrepreneurs giving strategies that
you can apply As You observe other
people getting coached and where we also
let you know about cool stuff that is
happening today's video is brought to
you by vid iq.com slink you can grab a
30-day trial of vid iq's boost plan for
just a dollar and one of the coolest
things about the Boost plan let's uh
let's put it to the test here is uh the
AI coach and the AI coach is really chat
GPT integrated with a YouTube mindset
integrated with your channel so you you
give vid IQ permission to look at your
analytics look at your data and so
what's kind of interesting is you could
just click you know based on my channel
what video ideas do you have for me is
one of my favorites because again it's
based on my channel well why don't I
just use chat GPT because vid IQ is
better because it's impowered by Chad
GPT as they're um you know plugged into
it but with data from your channel and
then the overlay of making it assistant
you know kind of like you can you can
have prompts and filters and programming
around chat GPT so you don't have to be
a programmer and all technical you could
just grab vid IQ and even try it out for
just $ one so there's really no risk
there but here's what's kind of cool is
based on think media it just gave me
five ideas and common mistake series a
microphone reviews a comparisons those
are all pretty good but I'm also
curious uh if we said what strug
teic video ideas should I
make this
month that would earn the most money
when we start thinking about prompts
when it comes to AI I don't know what
the answer to the question is going to
be but let's see based on the data of
your channel um it's maybe get tell me
the same oh a YouTube growth case study
from scratch one year update no one's
been doing those productivity tips great
productivity tips of course everyone's
thinking productive in January that's
pretty good and uh it looks like it
actually just spit out the same thing
but anyway so you can uh ultimately
check out vid IQ give it a try for
yourself click around try the different
prompts uh explore them and that is just
the tip of the iceberg you have some
keyword research we were talking about
uh element electrolytes earlier and so
you can actually see that okay that's a
1500 people a month 2500 maybe element
review 3,000 a month and verify that
okay that would be a
cool like that's not a viral video it's
a practical search-based video of
somebody that's maybe trying to make a
buying decision after they you know hear
your review about it so it could be a
profitable video you don't have to have
a product review channel to do product
reviews if that was relevant for your
Niche and your brand and just happens to
be the electrolytes I'm drinking
lately um then you could do that as well
and again it sounds like they don't have
an affiliate Pro uh program Victoria who
is one of our think media team members
uh loves element and she's like a
Fitness Nutrition expert uh in her own
right she said they have like a referral
program and you could get free boxes if
you went directly through them but then
also there's other sites that sell them
and and you could just say hey check
them out on Amazon or you could give
them both options you put both links in
your descriptions couple different ways
to buy you could buy direct if you like
Amazon because it's Amazon Prime boom
links in the description down below so
anyways vid IQ is a powerful tool to
help you get insights to help you with
their AI coach and all of the above and
so check it out at vid iq.com slink
there's no risk make December your best
month by just investing $ one do to try
it out get better results even if you
cancel because what's kind of cool right
is we talked earlier about this being a
strategic
month I don't know how to get this off
the screen um there we go it's been a
minute since I've live Streed it's been
a long week I just got down
shooting 400 videos and seven I did like
a thumbnail batch I batch thumbnails
once a year um and I told Kyle as we
were batching thumbnails and Melissa I
was like I want to do three years
assuming I don't change my hair too much
or like shave my beard of thumbnails I
was sort of joking but when you take
batching to the extreme I'm like I want
to shoot and so there's like couple
hundred photos but I'm like I don't want
to actually like you know take a shower
again I just want to do it the one day
I'm with other people otherwise I'm just
at home with my family and my kids they
don't care my wife doesn't care it's not
true okay relax so we're gon to welcome
Alex on and I'm excited because Alex is
going to be sharing with us some of his
analytics and so Alex break down uh
thanks for coming on tell us a little
bit about your channel and um what
you're up
to well um the channel hi Sean thanks
for having me on um the channel in and
of itself is all about exterior sheet
metal so you know breaking that down a
little bit more we're doing do tutorials
on metal roofing we're doing tutorials
on um window trims anything like
exterior
siding anything like that and you know
in terms of audience who I'm trying to
Target would be the the
DIY uh Enthusiast I would say uh the
professional too I think we can go two
routes on this channel but um yeah
that's that's really the kind of in a
nutshell
uh explanation of the channel
so awesome um yeah I love it and thanks
so much for being a part of our
community we're pulling up Alex's
analytics right here so now we're
looking at November kind of a fun time
to review almost $500 ad Revenue ad
revenue is usually three days delayed so
um we won't really know about November
Revenue ex fully until probably December
3D um but looking good go for green we
got the green arrows up watch time up
subscribers consistent I know we all
want to grow faster but go for green is
the ethic like if we can have steady
progress forward that's something to
celebrate uh let's check out real time
views say see more on the right side
there real time
views um see more under there we go and
then what I love about this page is
publish date so if you scroll down a
little bit
published it when I see that 2022 short
that gets me excited because literally a
year ago you have a video still getting
views and we have our program video raet
Academy right that's the dream 2021
still getting views and how can we
repeat that as much as possible
especially in a niche like yours it's
not going to be super viral oftentimes
right because it's it's so specific but
what happens when you have hundreds of
videos that are a year old two years old
and you got a couple that we're on
screen right now still growing your
channel that's really cool and really
encouraging and so your real- time views
are looking great we can X out of there
and let me know any specific questions
would love to look through what you're
looking at here or any spe specific
questions you have about analytics the
um the main um question on my mind when
it comes to analytics I would love to
get into your mind in terms of okay I
know how not how often do you check
check your analytics because I know
we're probably all really we're doing
that at an at an unhealthy rate yeah
daily multiple times a day I know I do
first thing I do when I wake up it's not
good but that's what I do uh but what
when you hop into the desktop analytics
the mobile version is a little different
but the you know when you hop in here
where are you going first what are you
looking at in terms of I mean other than
Subs other than other than subscriber
count so so first go up to November
let's go last 90 days so i' like to go
last 90 days and then let's scroll down
and look at the top 10 videos in the
last 90 days so it's one thing for us to
say success leaves Clues make part twos
but it's another thing to Define what
that means what do we actually how do we
spot the videos that are being
successful shorts are doing very well
for you in terms of views um those seem
to be your big Winners that 2021 video
is obviously always a legendary video
have you tried to double down on that
how to install one have you done that a
couple times since then I I mean the uh
the howto stuff
really uh it always performs well this
um this is an outlier video this blind
review here that's sitting at 100 that's
like that's the big pop off video that
can you do affiliate marketing to this
stuff or are you already is that
possible yeah so that tool you see in
the
thumbnail is uh is has an affiliate link
to it what website does the affiliate
link have you made money there Amazon
yeah oh cool yeah it's it's brought in I
think we're I'm sitting at around a
hundred bucks a month from Amazon right
now sick uh it's probably due in part to
this video right
here uh but well listen to this so one
when I one tactic so let's get super
Tactical right now so I see that I hear
that I think about okay what is on brand
for you staying on brand for your
channel maybe broadening a little if
you've heard my dart board analogy it's
like you don't want to post a video
that's if you're playing darts with some
friends you don't want to post a video
that's like way off the board like your
friend was drinking too much and like
it's like bro like you didn't even hit
the dart board but Bullseye would be
like it would be like a architectural
sheet metal is in the title it's exactly
on the dartboard even on the edges might
be something related to like a tool or
just a tool comparison video like I
don't know why it might not even be
exactly about architectural sheet metal
and what's interesting about that is at
least getting that 100 bucks up a month
from Amazon is exactly what we just said
maybe maybe someone shopping for um
doing more DIY projects in December
they're looking for certain tools what's
the best this tool what's the best that
tool what's this versus that tool and
this could be stuff you already of
course have in your shop in your gar and
you could do verses and you're already
understanding V and you could they also
don't have to even be hard to do and
that is a Content format that could add
value to your audience keep it on the
dartboard but also pump up those
Affiliates and with some of your ranked
videos and whatnot if we're at 500 a
month on adrev and we get to 500 a month
on Amazon Affiliates that's not that far
off and also that that's a general
strategy but if you notice there just
looking at your top 10 I'm like
okay based on your unique channel that
is a very specific thing that would be
aligned with what you're doing if you
kind of just keep it all on BR brand
does that make sense yeah so this is
this is a tool review but it's like it's
my first Glimpse at it like we're
looking at it together first time right
so it it hit well I had there was some
people tell telling me that before the
video played Amazon had an ad for this
tool before this video played and I'm
think maybe maybe that was uh but that
that would that would cut you out that
would cut you out from affiliate you
would just get paid ad Revenue if they
click through on the ad gotcha yeah
because they wouldn't be clicking your
affiliate link that's in the description
by the way can we open up that video if
you and if not oh yeah just click on it
hit me with uh the the pen right above
analytics by the way look cool to see at
the Banger too $1,500 video that that
paid you hopeing encourages this wasn't
an exciting time right here I'll tell
you that little that little bump up
that's so rad but it's still going that
thing is and when we we have What's
called the Rocket R in our seven RS
that's what we mean by rocket like this
is some SpaceX stuff videoos flying
let's go um okay so if we go to the pen
and I want to really affirm you if
you're interested in getting this tool
hit this link great job at having it
right at the top link to the tool great
use of Genius links well well done and
so um awesome to see you just executing
like V principles uh you know very
sharply do you have a pinned comment
with the affiliate link as well I think
so okay don't leave just in case because
I don't know if we're just sharing your
Chrome window but that's that would be
the other tip all right let's head back
over to analytics and then hit um
content
oh here it is
content all right if we scroll down yeah
shorts do
well uh top shorts great okay short
traffic sources yeah shorts feed is Big
source of traffic great hit um
audience scroll
down how much time have you spent in
channels your audience
watches uh a a little see some of my
competitors but what what I have learned
from what my audience watches is the
quote unquote the niche that I'm in
Without Really or like the the niche
that I think I'm in versus the niche
that I'm in is is is directly correlated
to what my audience is watching and yes
some of these uh sorry some of these
channels are metal roofing
channels but you see you got tool review
Zone you got yeah you know what I mean
like you got tool review Zone we we talk
about it in our Niche Finder course we
talk about you know it's it like if you
want this to be a business it's smart to
have positioning not that you got to
change things around but it's a it's a
logical place where there's a lot of
Commerce taking place that you could
profit from um I think some homework
would be to take some time to to go
through
competitors um you're specifically
wanting to go go to their popular videos
and see what kind of
topics are are are most viewed see what
kind of thumbnails or title formats
because sometimes it's not even that
you're going to copy the topic because
it's maybe not exactly right for your
channel but if it was like this
weird 2x4
trick fixed du D du and you're like oh
this weird sheet metal trick so you just
could you use it kind of as like oh wow
that's a cool idea it's been verified in
its Effectiveness in my Niche macro
niche of more you know kind of
construction you and I could adapt that
so there's a lot of insight that could
come from there um and then what your
audience watches scroll down a little
bit where we can look at the videos so
then we got maybe some different shorts
and we can see final nail in the coffin
my crew changing the Leaky laundry box
so even watching some of those shorts
what do they have what did they do it
how did it start um and then you could
skip through those three pages a lot of
shorts all shorts yeah install metal
roofing professional
masonry yep okay interesting so so sorry
you're saying this is a great place for
future content uh strategy oh oh yeah
those two is and because you're also
you're understanding the psychology of
your Audience by saying okay what else
are they watching what types of videos
or what types of formats even because
again you might see like the guy
literally just walked into the room and
said two things and he was holding up
his phone I could do that tomorrow on
the job or on the you know like you're
like okay and so there's a lot of gold
and it's going to be of course there's a
lot we could learn from Mr Beast but
it's different so you want to be really
the Creator who understands Their
audience their Community the psychology
and the mindset of the type um I also
find it fascinating how
diverse what time viewers watch content
can be you're when ERS watch videos on
YouTube is entirely different than than
ours ours is kind of starts at 5:00 am.
it kind of Peaks at 7 look at weekdays
it's when people get off work yeah do
you upload at those times and that's
when so I experiment with shorts uploads
just to see who's on right and U they
always perform better at like I'm
usually posting 4 or 5 o'clock just to
you know for it to be there at the six
and 7 o' point and they are depending on
the short like I'm using Opus clip it's
chopping up everything from my long form
con I rarely upload an original Short
it's all repurposed from Opus and they
they perform well they bring awareness
to my long form content like when you go
to the traffic source for related videos
it's in there and it's working right
it's it's leading them to the long form
content not like we're not getting
thousands of views from related shorts
but they click on it right they know we
we're seeing the same that related
shorts is a great point and we're also
seeing an interesting thing kind of a
side tip but like we had this secret
video that we did for our tech guide and
we did an unlisted video yeah that was
titled click here for a secret video and
then we put that on related shorts area
now for all we did for us and this is
still actually active for uh anybody
watching if you go to think Tech
thinkgear guide.com we've got all the
answers to the biggest Tech cameras
lenses lighting FAQs we just wanted to
bring awareness to that but you can't do
clickable links in shorts so what we did
was a clickable link to a video of me
being like thanks for finding this
secret video if you haven't heard we're
doing a giveaway of a YouTube studio um
we have we've updated all of our answers
the entire thick media team put their
Collective genius together what's the
best camera right now the best lighting
best budget gear and then give a verbal
call to action to that and also put a
link in the description is there
anything outside of YouTube you're
trying to do to monetize or a website or
anything you're trying to
promote yeah I do I have a website with
courses available through Wix that and
then but I'm also building an email
list with that has no current purpose
right now other than just collecting
names and emails and that's just hitting
over a thousand well done so um there is
a capture there it's just there's no um
client Journey for them that's a whole
separate conversation that you'd want to
get dialed because that's so important
but imagine if you made a video that was
unlisted and that you said click here
for our secret group our secret video
and then all you said you're like hey um
you know Alex here if you haven't heard
and this is the the key is like if you
haven't heard I actually have an
insiders newsletter and on this
newsletter you're going to get this
benefit and this benefit and this
benefit I send out one email a week just
go to d d URL or click the link in the
description and all the growth on the
shorts whatever people click related
videos find the secret video secret
video gives call to action to email list
do that over two years your 10,000 email
list signups are now 10,000 20,000
people yeah sure and you know you can
also monitor the performance of that
unlisted video can you not oh totally
yes so we ours has like 2,000 views and
like 200 likes and tons of comments
people are like oh my gosh secret video
because it's kind of a so just I think
that it's really cool to think outside
of the box of how we could use related
video feature um okay so there's so much
we could cover I let's to spend a little
more time I want to get to Jason and we
also if you got a question and you're
watching coffee with canel put four
question marks before and after it let's
go to revenue
though scroll down a
little okay RPM
1099 that's higher than think great job
which is cool as shorts are and don't
stop that's why long form is the goat
the greatest of all time because if you
up your long form views yeah shorts 31
cents that's also high too usually for
us like four to six but 31 cents so your
RPM is high in period but 31 cents is
nothing compared to $10 right not that's
that's is that in because my program or
my settings are in Canadian so just keep
that in mind oh okay okay good fair
enough
so close to par but it would also speak
that your Niche is a higher RPM because
ours is Tech is and so that always
inspires me to do long form but then do
the C more thing we did earlier on the
revenue of your last couple months on
the the left there yeah how much you
earning and so this is interesting to me
and again what we're looking
at I should go into dark mode um is is
playback CPM on the right side there and
how it varies per month again there's
not a lot you could change here but I
would say this here's some
principles the student of YouTube
analytics is looking for
patterns
rhythms
Seasons looking for data sets and the
more you look at this different these
data sets the more you might say like if
I looked at this if I just wanted to
make one conclusion if you looked at
your playback CPM there I would I would
go on vacation in
March because the CPM is low as that I'm
not trying to come to that conclusion
but that would be a concl like and I
would look at it i' go and maybe I'd go
on vacation in January and and so that
that actually contradicts my experience
with what I just said but you got to
know your own rhythms this is a big
unlock because what we're um talking
about with like our think media team is
I'm kind of like listen like those our
team members that work we're trying to
build a world-class culture
so and and we value family and we value
hard work so our team gets six weeks off
a year that's what we've been working
towards Sabbath week two weeks of paid
vacation other extra four- day weekends
and stuff when we really hustle great
saying that I'm like of course we're
gonna take thanks to give me off well
we're hustling on Friday that is that's
that's the Super Bowl for us it's Black
Friday we're a tech champ it might not
be relevant for every channel but it's
relevant for us and and it's kind of a
mindset shift because I just look showed
you our analytics at the beginning of
this whole stream
right November December and January is a
whole another level of push so I try to
like encourage and this would be for the
individual Creator right you're actually
just talking to yourself and talking to
your family you're getting by like hey
honey and that's kind of you know if you
think about it it's like Sonia my wife
um we're we are actually established too
we have total you know Financial Freedom
but it's like babe you know not only for
the financial aspect for the fact that
our community is shopping right now it's
why we
do thinkgear guide.com right they're
shopping right now so we want to be
there to answer their questions this is
I would you could call it responsibility
it's our responsibility to be showing up
when people are looking for answers the
flip side there's different seasons so
I'm like we can make up the time other
if the team was like hey can I take a
little more of a break here or it's you
know summer or like February like
whatever The rhythms like yeah no big
deal hey can I take off Black Friday no
like you I mean there's a few people
that yeah it there's different like
roles here but you get what I mean it's
when it's time to show up we got to show
up and so the more you study The rhythms
of your channel that's encouraging and
it's also encouraging too because
sometimes we get too stuck in our
emotions uh in in the terms of there are
es and flows throughout a year it's not
just consist
different channels have differences in
December January and sometimes back to
school is going to be crazy for somebody
summer might be way up for a Travel
Channel and it might be down for
something else and so those are some of
patterns data sets rhythms Seasons
observations and then as you just
continue to absorb that data apply it to
maybe your content calendar your
schedule how you communicate with your
family I think some of those tips could
be
helpful yeah very helpful thank you Sean
I appreciate your time my friend Alex I
appreciate you was this a cool
conversation do you have some thoughts
to
implement well I uh in terms of T like
timing
seasonality and uh I it just I ideas
start flowing when you start talking to
me about that because like there's
there's certain uh Products that come
into play at certain times for metal
roofing for example right so I could you
know plan content around that right now
I'm in I'm kneed deep in a five-part
series on how to install standing
seam it's you know it's probably not
maybe someone's trying to wrap up their
their uh their project before the winter
comes right so it's just and then that
other one that 170,000 viewed video it
was the least edited one I had but I
think the timing had everything to do
with it because this tool hit Amazon and
people were just going silly about it
right so
it's really I mean it's a I'm in an
experimental phase big time right now
but I love that well I appreciate you
Alex thanks so much for being a part of
our community grateful for you and uh
great job it's cool to see I mean you
got money coming in growth on the
channel moment you're already doing
great so we're going from good to great
that's our actually theme for 2024 at
think media let's build let's cool all
right thanks thanks Sean yeah got you
got it take care all right what was your
uh moment smash like um and uh drop a
comment I'm here live we got Jason
coming on in a second if you have a
question put four question marks before
and after your question today is also
brought to you
by big Medias sal.com if you haven't
seen our cyber week sale you're going to
want to get it before the price goes up
you could get five courses for
$57 so if you're thinking about starting
or growing a YouTube channel in 2024
this is the complete package for growing
a successful YouTube channel uh you can
get Niche Finder our starter kit a
ticket to our YouTube roadmart uh
roadmap Workshop that's happening in
January next year YouTube shorts
masterclass and AI this is a crazy price
you get all five of these courses for
the low price of $57 if you go to think
Medias sal.com you can see all the
details if you're not serious about
YouTube or you're just kind of hanging
out um you know learning a little bit
from us and whatnot great stick around
for our free content but think about all
the different ways you could spend
57 I don't know you know some dinner out
a couple extra appetizers it's like the
price of two appetizers Sean where do
you get your appetizers out those are
some expensive appetizers I don't know
but think Medias sale.com so uh check
that out and then we got a question
coming in here before we get to Jason uh
what are your thoughts on using your
personal name versus a brand name
I've got three thoughts for you number
one it's a really good question people
wonder how do I name my YouTube channel
three options first and last name name
plus brand or brand name only so first
and last name your channel could be Shan
canel Tony Robbins shellene Johnson Gary
vaynerchuk Alex Hermos first and last
name it's a personal brand great second
idea your channel could be cooking with
Karen barbecue with Bob cooler if it
Rhymes kind of cool because you get what
you're doing or it also might not make
as much sense it might be like the
future with Fred like what is a
technology Channel I'm not sure what
that is
so I love that because you might even
cut your last name off and put more of
the niche or the brand or something
about it like real estate tips with
Ralph and if you were for some reason
named by your parents with a name that
doesn't rhyme with your Niche I'm sorry
that's me too YouTube tips with Yousef
my name should have been Yousef but my
name is Sean but my Sean Kell rhes with
YouTube channel though so okay and then
lastly think
media um other ones you know like a
brand name like so uh you could just
name your channel you know Film Riot you
know and and it's up to you so here's
the questions when it comes to
deciding is what is it you're ultimately
trying to build what is your long-term
Vision uh if you get into gaming it's
sometimes you know it might be like
Razer
55x 22 or you know different Gamers kind
of different culture so kind of
understanding you know what is it you
want to communicate what what is your
what is your dream what is you what do
you want to build and I don't know if
you can actually get it wrong although I
do think if you get it right it's
incredibly helpful like again if you
could go cooking with Karen it's like oh
cool I know her name's Karen and then I
obviously know what the channel is about
about cooking so I think those are a few
thoughts at the end of the day um one
other tip I would give you is if you
think like a business owner and not just
like a hobbyist Creator which is our
goal at our company is no whether you're
kind of on the Creator path you just
want to be pure Creator economy even
with an entertainment Channel or you
already are business minded person
because you're a service provider a
business
owner all of us need to be thinking like
business owners like Jay-Z said I'm not
a businessman I am a
businessman and a business person would
also say is the website available is the
social media handles available is the
trademark
available where's the where do I want to
build over the next 5 to 10 years
now you don't have to answer all those
questions because you might be like
relax bro I just want to name myself
like Razer 55 kick Kat you know like
okay you know I don't ever want to have
a website well that would be your vision
then but if you if you were thinking
like I want to build a brand like and
you might just be saying what if like
when sitting down and name a channel you
might say what if this was something
bigger one day like when my friend Benji
and
I um started video influencers which is
kind of like sideline back burner
project but grew to 700,000 subs or
whatever and we you know wrote YouTube
Secrets together
before we even posted a video I think we
bought videoinfluencers.net
eventually for like 12 bucks I think we
got videoinfluencers.net
and we got the Instagram and we got the
Twitter now X and we got the Facebook
page so we also were thinking about
brand and not just a YouTube channel
name so we actually go um into this in a
very heavy way inside of our Niche
Finder course one of the best things you
could do this month is go through our
Niche Finder course if you want to get
clear on your topic maybe you're going
to Pivot or reposition your channel a
lot of our our V students you may
already have that in your members area
uh but it's also part of our um bundle
as well so I hope those tips added value
and that's one of the reasons why you
don't want to sleep
on our Hol they offer because uh there's
I maybe covered half of the Strategic
questions not even of just kind of like
brand Niche where's this going
positioning big picture so think Medias
sale.com skip the
appetizers pick up the Cyber week sale
think Medias
sale.com all right we got a Super Chat
I'm going to come back to you AO hammer
in a bit some great questions coming in
but we gotta get to Jason
Jason welcome to the show tell us about
your channel yes uh our channel so a
friend of mine uh and I were discussing
about a year ago hey we've got friends
that are getting separated divorced how
can we help our buddies in their
marriages and other men in their
marriages and so we came up with this
idea to help men Thrive and uh so we
started a YouTube channel and podcast
and so we've been at it for about a year
and uh we're learning lots and changing
things as we go uh but we're we got 138
subscribers it's like okay we how do we
break out I think that's friends and
family and a few people let's how can we
break out of that it's amazing so first
of all thanks so much for coming on and
being a part of our community and then
secondly love the vision marriage is
tough we've been married 18 years we're
in counseling right now uh we've been in
different seasons in counseling we're
hitting a whole new season uh as a side
quest um we also just realized Sony and
I that they say what are the top
stressors that hit a family they say
moving is one of them or remodeling
we're doing that up in the Northwest and
trying to juggle living in two states
with kids and families and we're kind of
moving more Washington because of family
but that's happening
um one-year-old and three-year-old kids
and kids at certain ages okay that's
happening um health challenges my wife
especially got we both kind of have some
stuff but she's got she's been in the ER
in the last couple weeks that's a whole
another level you add chronic illness or
health challenges that's happening um
and then you add trying to run a
business together um co-own a business
and so we also realized amongst mainly
my weaknesses and failures and foibles
that I'm trying to grow in that the
circumstance and season that we're in so
anyways I can feel the need of what
you're talking about to strengthen
marriages to impact and so just thank
you for the work you're doing and um so
we we of course want to help
purpose-driven leaders like yourself and
so great job this is needed so let's
blow it up awesome thank you so
um why does this say how to buy a
business
I mean
why that is one of our you're you're
covering multiple topics it's not just
uh marriage family and business helping
Thrive family and business thank you
okay and and let me read the top then
okay so helping men thrive in family and
business so you also your content would
be like directed at me if you're the
target market yeah yeah if you happen to
be in business and in family together
okay great just helping me I it was
there all along helping me connect the
dots Perfect all right all right well
let's look at some things the first
thing that stood out to
me is there's too many words it gets
worse as we go down but there's too many
words even right here it's almost
like got I got a couple opinions cover
images are overrated like how much
impact they have but I'm gonna be honest
I don't think saying weekly shorts or
saying monthly episodes even matters I
don't think frequency needs to be said I
don't think anyone because here's what
happens no one reads it and holds you to
it right and a lot of people just fail
on it anyways like myself incl you're
like weakly shorts and then you miss a
week so what happened you think someone
was like oh I can't believe they did it
like they only it's they see it if you
post new content they see it if the
algorithm suggested they don't see it
because like oh you know what I'm gonna
do hey Siri remind me that the Lifeguard
you know like so so I'm just what I'm
asking here is what words can we remove
sure so
um The Lifeguard show I might also say
it's cool the logo is there but it's
also here and it's also on the
handle I think helping men thrive in
family and business theoretically could
be the most stripped down and then it
makes it even more powerful because when
we when we take away it just accentuates
the message helping men thrive in family
and business which is a
incredible
um tagline Mission side note do you have
36 kids just nine Sean okay you know
what they say nine is Good Start yeah I
that's what they say
um okay so and then and then the we help
men I'm not I don't love it you know I I
almost like it's all right but I don't
love it it's because it's different
because then it's a we help man I mean
it's clear I suppose but you know I do
say lifeguard
show I don't know why the G is lowercase
right here I'm I'm nitpicking this isn't
even what I appreciate it so we talked
we were like okay we're going to start a
channel let's call it the Lifeguard show
we're helping men guard their lives and
now you know it's perhaps you know you
confuse you lose we're getting a little
bit of that the story brand thing so
we're trying to differentiate I change
it I know it's painful I'm going I'm I'm
cutting right in and I'm going with my
gut because I hate the worst thing in
the world is having to change your and
not that you have to but if you think
long term like my background working at
a church a church changing their name
and I was the director of communication
person and the social media manager you
want to talk about the person in the
meeting that does not want the church to
change their name like do you understand
the ramifications of US changing all the
social media and all the YouTube and all
the logos and all the work I've done and
every old sermon and every old logo and
every letter head and everything that
we've done and are you kidding me and
the brand we've built the level of
stress let's not change the name I get
the angle of like not wanting to do it
but then what would your 10 to 20 year
from now self say right if you like if
you pulled the Band-Aid off and got your
brand right the the reason I'm
passionate about it I don't think you
have to but lifeguards just means
something different right so when we try
to be
creative and people understand the
mental gymnastics we had to because
because what it meant and I get I get
exactly what it means but even in two
seconds okay so the Lifeguard show and
and maybe that's what we're looking at
the whole thing it's like we help man
The Lifeguard show weekly shorts there's
kind of a lot happening and you just
want to cut straight through the
noise on on an on an interesting thought
I mean you could have your face are you
guys equal on the podcast well we I live
in Canada maybe it's the Canadian show
today I think Alex said he's can
Canadian 2o are you
Partners well we're friends and so when
we're together we filmed some episode
and now we filmed some interviews
separately on different occasions you
have a contract for what this is and
what GNA be
no what happens when the money comes in
you just think it's gonna be 5050 or
great question yeah that's what we
think probably a good time to get some
of that really good time to get some of
that clear yeah you you both committed
to this for the next 100
years yes you define who does what by
when and who carries responsibility
and to some degree we Define that in our
conversations not on the
contract who who edits the videos we
hire an editor
okay
so I didn't even think we'd take it here
but might be this could be one of the
most valuable of your life maybe this is
yeah
because
um just thinking
ahead thinking through questions if it's
not written it's not real getting
Clarity on paper thinking about who does
what by when playing out scenarios
having some deep
conversations um because the other thing
to think about is you've already
invested time and energy in 68 videos
but you you're paying for an editor
right now you're probably paying you
guys are investing at without a profit
is that accurate that is accurate so so
on our last couple videos actually so I
signed up for an Amazon affiliate link
based on ideas from V when I started a
couple months ago I've only used it in
our last like two shorts which you can't
even click on a link in a short so it's
but it's like okay I've got it connected
to my personal Amazon account and I
thought through some of the things you
said there okay so I don't even know how
you get paid from an Amazon affiliate
but it's going to come to my account I
think so do Ryan way I don't know any
other way to do it like even in a
business
context it's like a personal affiliate
account I don't know if you could do
affiliate accounts on Amazon to a bit
like you can bookkeeping can track that
but I've been in a similar situation
where so it's a lot of things to Think
Through the other thing that's
interesting is like I think do you guys
have a business
plan
no so I think
that the work you're doing it would seem
as you're just getting started and
building your family um almost at
scratch you know with just a few more to
go are you gonna have
more uh well there may be more on the
way perhaps if announ already on the way
there's all kind having like awkward
conversations about business
Partnerships you're announcing your
wife's pregnant and you've told nobody
else just me not even your family it's
on Christmas
I mean you didn't actually say that but
you sort of implied it and then I just
shined a giant Spotlight on it and we
just we're going to all kinds of places
on coffee with candle today let's go
number 10 is on the way Sean wow okay
that's a good number too so man I just
think um I think and you're V Elite yes
sir yeah so I think
that it would seem just getting to know
you right now right that
your experience what you both know your
passion your mission is sound the
business models you can build around
what you're doing are also sound to make
enough money for the mission even
without a big audience and then over
time the audience keeps growing and
growing and growing but actually maybe
things not even blowing up or going
crazy yet is one of the greatest
blessings in Disguise
because thinking about who else would we
maybe need to hire it's kind of like one
one of my favorite books is your next
five moves by Patrick B David and one of
my favorite parts of the book is in one
of the last chapters where he actually
lists his 15 moves of building value
tainment and you start seeing seeing a
couple things not just what to do next
but also
sequencing and this is also why nobody
is
copyable like somebody can say I'm just
going to copy what Shawn did I can kind
of observe you actually can't even see
what I'm doing because you don't know my
sequencing you don't know that I do this
or do that or how I hired this person
and I did this thing and I may to have
this conversation and we had to get this
and right and we had to get the brand
right for because somebody else too they
also could have their own sequen in may
work may
not and so it's sort of I'm
thinking
okay you have a personal work to do
personal questions where I want this to
go what's my dream scenario how much
many hours a week do I want to do what
do I want to do now we've been here but
where are we going in the future you've
then got your partner's thoughts on that
you've then got saying how much more
money do we need to risk and invest how
what is it going to take to get Velo
like escape velocity um do we need to
sideline that do we want to build and
what I say about this because you have a
real coaching opportunity for men
courses and coaching or education for
men and helping them in a like I was
thinking one of our students that's
doing intermittent fasting is doing
12,000 a month um
Affiliates brand
deals ad
Revenue but about six or seven or eight
K from coaching family and business it's
so needed so so if you also know okay
we're basically going to that's part of
the sequence but it's also just because
it's one part A lot of people mistake
this they think okay when I gotta like
sideline and build that now not
necessarily you just might be like okay
that's going to be probably in the six
to 12 month window out but here's here's
what we need to get right we need to
jump on with Sean and talk about the
channel but before we also start doing
the channel so okay what's the brand
look
like is there a logo for the brand
because I was also thinking a logo and I
this whole conversation spun off just
looking at the Avatar thinking should it
be your face or should it be his face
right could you put your both faces in
there the other question would be even
talking about is it actually more
5149 um just open-handed conversation
because personal
opinion I wouldn't do 5050 business
other than with my wife right and I'm
grateful for everything I've done BEC
but just because I don't even I really
don't even know if it's possible Right
5149 clarifies a ton while
giving essentially absolute equal
benefit
but it sort of shows
who who's who's going to be there
forever who's gonna and and then also
like even exit Clauses you want to know
how how you could exit or how you could
transition should something happen
should whatever and I think sometimes
we're afraid of all these conversations
another good book is difficult
conversations and crucial
conversations you maybe the conversation
isn't even difficult when it starts but
it gets difficult and and you play
things out what happens when the
business is making a million dollars a
year who gets to decide who you hire and
who who who who you fire or how you risk
that money or how much risk you take
that's why 5140 who's the final decision
you have to come to a consensus on every
decision try try being married to your
business partner maybe you are as well
uh you know like is it
consensus
so um what I was interesting is like
looking at the channel I almost was like
it would be so powerful if this was like
a c or a logo or a
movement the book eventually comes out
but who writes the book are you
co-authoring it and you obviously have
seen which this is also pretty
remarkable Benji Travis is still one of
my best friends work out together we
co-authored YouTube secrets we own video
influencers 5050 one of the benefits of
doing that and we own the book 5050 one
of the benefits of doing
that that has helped it work is both I
think of our Grace and personalities and
and forgiveness and and conce eting at
different times but also that him and
his wife have a main thing their Vlog
and then I got think media and so we
kind of have like a collab project a
little bit different but I learned so
many lessons too and and look back with
nothing but gratitude and I'm also
stunned uh because it's kind of rare
like I think Dave Ramsey said
Partnerships stink because they all sink
or something there's some quote like
that or whatever it and it's and then me
put on another side there's there's like
probably no apple without Steve wnc and
Steve Jobs another good book
um
is how I built this the book let's throw
this into the I don't know uh if we're
capturing these ones Victoria but I I
can't remember which on did I already
tell you Jason next time well you said
crucial conversations I crucial
conversations next moves how I built
this the book we'll throw those in the
description those are affili links this
is a wild book for you in particular
there is a whole and and it's actually
he's got a great podcast but next moves
that was another one yeah this is so
synthesized um
meaning rather than having to dig
through sometimes people say like oh why
should I buy YouTube Secrets I could
just watch all the
videos and eventually get all the points
you're like yeah but you that you want
to know what's more efficient
the synthesized book it'll actually save
you time to listen to the 4-Hour audio
book rather than listening through 40 to
80 hours of YouTube videos with all the
other and so this book is so dense with
business wisdom but there's a whole
chapter I wish I could get to the uh
uh e copy n yeah like the the like just
the look
inside so let me see here how I built
this anyways and they have a whole
chapter on why if you're going to build
something great partnership is great I'm
not even trying to so there's all
different opinions about Partnerships
perhaps for what it's worth and it's all
a grain of salt but 5149 is just that's
still it's so close to 5050 but it
clarifies so much yeah and it would
clarify that like listen I'm gonna carry
this thing to the end no matter what I'd
love to go the whole way it's going to
be easier for you to have exit ramp do
you see it going that far do you want
want it to go that far do you want to
write a book do you want to coach do you
want to work 40 hours a week do you want
to work 20 hours a week how often do you
want to do that do you want to do that
for the next 10 years do you want to do
that just for a season do you want to
keep this as a hobby if you were given
this scenario and by the way very
gracious and open-handed perspective is
also you start if you guys could sit in
front of a
whiteboard and
follow you know for the sake of time we
could kind of land the plane of I've
asked Maybe 5% of the questions you
should ask just open so we've talked
about lots of stuff big picture hey
conferences couples
cruises like we got locked we all over
the place it's like okay well what are
the sequences that's a takeaway out of
this what on paper does this mean am I
paying for the cruise and then if it
flops you know I'm the guy selling my
house you know yeah who who takes out a
helck when we have to do you do it too
and I do it too how much Equity do you
have at your house like yeah you know to
get all these but like it there's a lot
of different things that could come up
um and that wisdom from video
influencers was it was hyper
lean so that was one thing
where there was a there was like a risk
threshold had an amazing editor named
Gabby still collaborating with Beni
doing some other stuff and and uh but
like in Mexico so the editor was Lean
Like ad Revenue could cover some things
this could cover some things but we
didn't run a conference together we like
if I was going to take on the risk of a
conference I wanted to I wanted to take
it on myself you know like whatever so
so the possibility of multiple entities
the clarity of okay this is kind of a
collab Channel this could do this but
like I want to build the coaching thing
and this and I didn't really want to do
that as well a lot of different
directions you could go so so um
this is fun I didn't think we were going
to go here this is a business coaching
uh for here except that we don't really
have a business yet because we haven't
got one Plum nickel out of this thing
we've just dumped our nickels in so did
you uh create an entity
no um and I either did I for quite a
while like it we actually got pretty far
at think media we actually started video
influencers right up front because
that's more how Benji would lean we had
a LLC before I think we posted a first
video think media I was a sole
proprietor and we had like 10
contractors working here already or
something like that no employees yet
because you can still I think run it
lean I think in a way llc's could be
overrated but as I grow in wisdom
liability is smart taxes is smart
bookkeeping is smart um and okay so
let's keep it any final question on the
business and then I'll give you a few
YouTube
tips well we got a lot to think about
and he he's a CEO of a company and so
he's got some business you know from
their family business he's been in and
as I've been in a family business too so
we can go a lot with the business stuff
but yeah branding uh name Logo you can
see if you look at our older videos
literally red with a white cross on it
like really jumping into the lifeguards
thing and as people are like you know no
no get away from the lifeguards thing we
pivoted and got rid of the Crossing made
it blue but maybe there's another step
to yeah and I mean you're in V Elite I
think connecting with Brook uh and Brian
both higher level branding Geniuses and
and positioning because what I also you
know what's interesting is like we for
example I don't have a copy of YouTube
Secrets but we we
architected the entire
Channel um um before we ever posted a
video we knew we were doing
this and we worked backwards with
growing our email list and whatnot and
now 110,000 copies
sold whole thing was
intentional
so the right book on marriage in
business with the right title with the
right information with the right email
list built to it with the sequencing by
the way that was an entire SE it was a
sequence sure and I we it all started
when Benji picks me up from the airport
he would hire me to film videog um to do
videography for them um I had a whole
income stream from doing freelance video
I was his wedding videographer I had
been helping pastors and leaders build
their YouTube channels he had um all
kinds of YouTube connections on like the
YouTube celebrity entertainment side and
him and his wife had a vlog he had had a
real estate Channel and had this whole
ranking videos locally in the Pacific
Northwest experience I had ranked videos
in Tech already and not even close to
what we had done today but by
2015 we are like wow we know quite we
know a lot about YouTube we have a lot
of YouTube experience and there's no
definitive book on YouTube there's a
bunch of ebooks and like lower quality
stuff um what if we were a really great
one um we would have had quite a bit of
good things to say at that moment but we
um didn't um
uh uh we it got even better based on
what happened next but this would show
the principle there would be the power
of like starting before you're ready or
the power of like committing and then
and doing something but then being
willing to Pivot along the way because
we're driving in the car and I had just
gotten off a Southwest flight listening
to Lewis hows on the school of greatness
podcast and you interviewed Tucker Max
and Tucker Max launched a company called
book in a box and then eventually it was
called scribe and Scribe just went
bankrupt and now they're back and so
what a journey it's been but scribe has
been amazing so they're kind of like a
ghost
writer that you're actually the writer
after hours and hours and hours of
interviews but they synthesize it and
why because are we both going to just go
to Google Docs and and type and we're
not even necessarily going to be great
one of the reasons why YouTube Secrets
is a really really great book is it's
really really well written and easy to
read why because a really good writer
wrote it not their information our
information and our stories and our so
when I heard about that I was like what
would you think if we did this and we
went 5050 on the cost of booking a box
11,000 at the time 1,000 off because of
Lewis House's link now it's 40,000 we
got a good discount locked it in but
then because of good mentors and
investing in programs like V Elite one
of my mentors shellene Johnson I
remembered her saying she
said she is New York Times bestseller if
I'm gonna launch a
book I want to have an email list first
period end of story that's the thing I
want which I would also say if you're
going to launch coaching you could do it
other ways but you got to be building
your email list so then I realized okay
yes YouTube channel but email list needs
to be the thing and so then we set a
goal we are not going to release the
book until we have 25,000 people on our
email list sequencing so then we said
okay maybe I can make some think videos
maybe he can shout it out on his Vlog
then we thought everything that you're
learning in V Elite and the power of
being connected to thinking about this
stuff we thought okay what if
um
uh have we built though not just an
email list but even subscribers and an
audience that would actually want to
build this book exactly what you're
doing now because it's family and
business we're like we need to start a
new YouTube channel it wasn't even the
first thought we were like right
bestselling book based because we love
YouTube and we've got seven years of
experience each already by
2015 okay but if we do it right as we we
committed we paid the money put money
half down on scribe paid the money but
then we're like okay slowed down a
little bit now we got to build let's
actually like start a new YouTube
channel so we shot a video that holiday
season while I was back you could see
the original trailer shot the video and
then started committing to interviewing
uh video influencers not just because
it's smart but also because imagine
would the book be better if we talked to
a hundred experts
entrepreneurs or worse if we hadn't talk
you know it would be better because it's
not just our wisdom it's other people's
wisdom and then the process we got
better on building think we're building
video influencers we're learning a lot
it actually delayed the book by four
years but I would argue four years of
Blood Sweat and Tears went into the book
it's probably why 110,000 copies have
been sold Ryan holiday perennial seller
another book to read if you want to
write a book so uh ultimately yes
uh we ended up with like a 100,000
people on the email list video
influencers was much more successful
than we thought it would be momentum
happened but was also and here's what's
interesting I will say we could have
done a lot better in our business plan
but there was one objective of this
whole project YouTube
secrets that so we can look back this
was the objective now it's kind of cool
that we just did the second edition
which doesn't show up on the paperback
although it is the second edition so
it's the updated second edition so we we
just got together we re-recorded the
audiobook things have been cool it's
it's living on but it was the one
objective and but also as we saw things
expand now actually Benji's got some his
own coaching think is now my focus we
have our own event there's also been
some good and that is powerful because
even though we had to have some
conversations as things evolved it the
the sequencing was build Channel build
email list launch book both benefit from
book serve a lot of people and that's
what we did and here we are and and of
course it's like a mixture of hard work
hustle luck timing Faith God's grace all
of the above and it's all by God's grace
yes and it's
all very
intentional we're not talking and I
don't I didn't sell 110,000 books by
accident sequencing like planned out the
whole thing so I think that you it's now
we we've got V Elite and we got coaches
and so I also started realizing Okay the
reason I uh I couldn't have gone to what
what we're doing now in in a 50-50
situation
um I could have I suppose but I just
mean like as I started to see because
you also start our vision was the book
but was the vision five years with Grow
video live and this amount of hustle and
what is your lifestyle on five daughters
and what is my lifestyle where is your
lifestyle over the next five to 10 years
so what's so cool again still best
friends project successful recently
we're just sharing a meal together and
talking about man how crazy to just look
back that we sat down and we made a plan
and we did the plan and we got here it
wasn't exactly how we thought and like
look over now and you're doing this and
I'm doing this but then there was also
so and by the way so much more we could
not see I can see it now having been
through the process I'm really grateful
because I think for our entire Community
because for the percentage of us there's
probably a hundred ideas that you never
would have thought of maybe you thought
about starting a Channel with somebody
else how's it divided what's happening
and so it's a pretty deep comp
but um there's I shared that rather long
story to talk about kind of sequencing
intentionality sitting down and then
thinking about starting with the end in
mind of I think the book is a good model
for you because and really what the
model would be
is book framework proprietary process
potentially one- Day event multi-day
event online course and coaching but
it's all the same thing like that would
be kind of the expert model or the
infopreneur model that somebody could
get in with you at a free level in a
book level and an ebook level and they
could and you and you don't build all of
that overnight and you don't have to
necessarily do all of those pieces but
that would be thinking about where this
could all go and then in doing
so you know who car does what by when
what do they carry Etc okay so any
followup questions on
that yeah lots but that good enough for
now I guess I don't know you know you so
you had your own thing going you and the
other guy partnered and continued having
your own things going on the side and
then you expanded your thing it s it
just sounds like hopefully I can be
where you are in 10 years because it
sounds like our paths are on a similar
thing but you defined things and you
split off and grew your own thing while
growing a thing together also yeah and
and also even through different
challenges and whatnot I think it's
trying to get as clear and as simple on
paper of like what are we solving for
like so how could we Define winning
level one book is out book is successful
book is selling by the way also like if
you will passive income yes we still
Market it um and still work on it I I
don't want to say that it's passive and
other people help do that but in the
sense that it's done the cool thing
about building your own products what we
all should be thinking that we're
listening to coffee with canel is how do
I create something once that can pay me
without having to recreate it over and
over again which would be different than
actual interactive coaching a book is
one of the best ways to do that I think
every I think every content creator
should write a book it it'll make you a
better content creator it forces you to
synthesize your ideas if you write a
book that has a framework there's a
million things we could say as a side
note in your particular situation with
absolutely no sales intent other than
your situation is very unique it could
be interesting and I know you're already
investing in VRA Elite and other things
just throwing it out there and maybe
it's not now but maybe it's in three
months or six months just something to
consider that it it might be valuable
for you and I to talk in an official
sense and I do you know like my coaching
um Andor or the three of us um just BEC
also you start thinking about you know I
mean my coaching is 4,000 an hour um
somebody's doing a half day with me for
12 Grand and so and that's not a I mean
like sounds like you're I'm not like no
just putting I get it yeah we've both
but also if you're building a multi6
figure business or a million dollar
business that is it's nothing compared
to heartache and pain and confusion and
by the way lawsuits and and inefficiency
and employees that maybe you hired but
it was confusing and so it was a waste
because it was It was kind of toxic
there just a lot of things that could
happen not saying that any of that
happened no lwuit or anything but but it
absolutely could happen so it can
actually getting wisdom the Bible says
right buy wisdom in the message
paraphrase uh though it cost you
everything you have more valuable than
rubies more precious than gold depending
on what you want to build investing in
someone to help you process through see
down the road think about things and
getting it set up right man it pays so
much that's why I also I'm paying
somebody right now $48,000 a year and
that's the grandfather rate from his
$75,000
fee it's a bargain that is a sale might
sound crazy but it's a sale for the
problems I have you know it's a sale for
the economics that we're at so just the
different levels yeah okay so can we hit
a few YouTube tips as we land the plane
let me know anybody that's uh got some
unlocks from this I know some people
probably like okay let's talk YouTube
thumbnail strategies and whatnot but
this is some of the meat on the bones
and that list of books for your
particular situation man how I built
this is going to be amazing I listen to
the A audio book but I think the thing I
was getting after is there's like a um
there's like a partnership chapter and
it was fascinating to actually I hope
you don't think I'm the conclusion
actually was not even anti- what you
guys could build together what he would
teach is that nothing great was built
without a partner on your own yeah but
it doesn't mean yeah and and teamwork
for sure is necessary to make the dream
work but but the idea of 5050 I think is
interesting and and and I mean I don't
know there's all kinds of different
views on leadership but end of the day
there's got to be someone that has that
final decision power there's a there's a
reason why certain Founders and CEOs
even when they get boards and stuff take
like four of the seven seats because
there's just something
about things inevitably will get complex
or something at one point and and you if
you have it prepared there let's play
out the other way I've seen so many
YouTube collab
channels fail stop um hit a wall hit a
and and I would argue they didn't have
to but they maybe just didn't go into it
with okay I think we made that point all
right rapid fire tips on some
thoughts um while maybe everything we
just talked about encourages you to
pause for a bit great um
I uh am still wanting less words yeah
not just up here but on every thumb
yeah well you'll see the trend is as you
go up less words okay good you're so
that's that Evolution based on my review
from v a month ago was like now I'm
trying to get to no words on yesterday's
or this week's post um and then I mean a
maybe one other thought is I think just
staying in v and staying in V Elite
because packaging but even your choice
of topics like so how to buy a
business um is such a bad title
in
2024 and here's why because it's it's
too short it's too
vague somebody might argue like no it's
pretty clear how to buy a business yeah
but like for who with what size of
budget with what situation with Venture
with bootstrap with and so the essence
of V would even just be how to buy a
business in GTA 5 it's an incred
incredible different that's a virtual
business in a video game it's different
um without money with seller financing
I'm already I am a thousand times more
excited if you if that video was how to
buy a business with seller financing
because I don't I need like two or three
more distinctions on that and I would be
thinking about that topic-wise
you know are you a
helicopter parent I don't like that I
don't like family worship ideas I like
family worship ideas three words I don't
even know what we're talking and I don't
know like nobody was like okay you know
what um I'm just wondering like what is
there any family worship
ideas I mean parent maybe there is JW
Jehovah's Witness worship ideas creative
Family Worship ideas how do families
worship best practice Family
Worship so but anyways what we're after
is topics I would argue this as you
master V Elite and V like you you'll
continue to get those but that's what I
would be after if I was um you I think
it's interesting you know one of value
tanit's guys is I would I would really
study V Masters you know the the deeper
section of RA and look at Trend surfing
and influence surfing I think Tom
Ellsworth that's on the value tment team
so he's the biz doctor and one of the
cool things about that positioning is
his
shows are all Trend and influence
surfing so so he what he he's he's
diagnosing and breaking down the recent
open AI case study about the CEO getting
fired by the board of directors and blah
blah blah so he's talk so in his
thumbnail the Wei work so this is
influence greater than his own right so
I just think it's interesting to me
there's many ideas I could have but that
was the one I wanted to share with you
that hit me like simplify you know
Topics in general but you got to attach
your influence when you're growth
hacking the brand early on I think the
two of you interviewing virtual
interviews I think also the idea that
like you start getting into things where
it looks like you guys fly together you
live in a different place but you fly to
the same place to record we have done
that yes and now streamyard I've been
playing around with I think that's our
next step while we're remote streamyard
is about to drop 4K but can you do solo
rounds with
um with uh Henry
Cloud could you do a solo round with
Henry Crow who wrote boundaries right I
mean I'm actually could you like you're
that's what we're like who do we want
we're like we want Willie Robertson so I
email Phil and Willie Robertson and I
get Form results it's like okay well now
we know they want us to have a million
followers you know before that wasn't
the number but it was like SE okay if
we're gonna go remote and interview some
of these guys some of the things you
think though too you also think could
you pay for it right uh like just
curious and then but also when you make
your dream 50 dream 100 list of people
you want to interview but also do you
have to interview them together whatever
but I'm just saying it sometimes it's
simpler because also you could Benji and
I would also trade off in the video like
he would do one I would do so just
different things but like communication
overcommunication but to the point of
trend surfing um and influence surfing I
just
wonder you know of
course you value integrity and you would
think about how you would talk about you
know other stuff but when information is
public like let's say of a celebrity
couple or a business couple or a
business marriage so so you talk about
what can we learn from Jeff Bezos and
his divorce yeah I mean I'm sure a lot
and with respect to all parties involved
but and then by doing your due your
research side note as I get to know you
and know your brand I might I'm by the
way I probably am not now this is just
me I don't want to completely I hope you
don't feel
like I came here for you to help me and
I would probably skip the family worship
ideas I'm probably would I would skip
cultivating your character I would skip
theia couldn't stop this entrepreneur
because I'd be like what entrepreneur
and I mean but by the way if I'm if I
like have dyslexia I probably would
click on that well so that was kind of
the ask ask specific questions title I'm
like okay how can I ask specific
questions there like dyslexia I don't
care about dyslexia but there's a bunch
of people that do and is anyone talking
to them
so yeah all the that makes sense but I
don't know cure for dyslexia
entrepreneur like and and so that's we
could go more on topic but here's my
point if if I'm
subscribed like our other 138 people and
I'm you know trying to make a choice and
it's like seven
lessons businessmen can learn from Jeff
bezos's divorce right and Jeff Bezos is
in the thumbnail I'm
like okay like I'm just I'm I'm just
saying you'd get my attention and that's
what I would stop the scroll and
and so that's only one strategy but my
thought is it's if you look at what the
biz doctor is doing again so Tom elworth
is a genius in his own right but if he's
like hey how to buy a business I'm like
okay well I also don't want to buy
business right now but if it's business
lessons from you know I'm like wow this
whole chat GPT and he's responding to
things that are happening those things
as you growth hack this the mastering of
these strategies in the hardest season
of all which is the season you're in
getting the algorithm going kind of
getting discovered getting your brand
they don't know you yet they don't know
your guys' wisdom yet what do they know
Trends culture influencers maybe a
particular topic that is why we attach
to growth hack our channels what is
influential in my case cameras are
actually influential people know what a
Canon R50 is and a Sony zve ten0 is so
they go search for that and they did not
know Shawn yet then they met Shawn
and a certain percentage were like never
want to listen to that guy again great
you know definitely I heard you in the
comments bro certain percentage hit the
dislike button luckily it's like less
than 5 percent but you know you get it
and then some people are like oh like
this is kind of valuable you know click
subscribe and then I just did that for
10 years and you know and built it up
but it's the kind of a growth hacker
mindset and I would for the one strategy
I'd definitely be thinking about Trend
surfing and influence surfing as it
pertains
to family and business divorce so I've
kind of been thinking about that in the
book world so I just put up two shorts
like books for men Wild at Heart Rich
Dad Poor Dad those are the two books I
just put out it's like okay can I piggy
back on some of that somehow I don't
know I'm putting them out there you can
and and and last tip we gone super long
but last
tip is secret to get interviews now you
still got to get some influence going uh
because people they are selective but I
mean it's also it's kind of like a list
b list and C list you think about that
at C at a c or maybe even a B level it
doesn't matter the audience sze maybe
they just want the content maybe they
can repurpose it and you start reaching
out that way Hey listen we record in
stream yard and it's 4K we give you the
raw file so you can edit it like you you
you you're pitching a different value
like Hey we're getting started I would
love to and you also might say I
remember early on in video influencers I
think I paid the money out of my own
pocket maybe we paid it out of our
company budget or whatever which was
very small it was like a pool Benji and
I Lewis house school of greatness seven
eight years ago he's also kind of just
starting said hey LS can I interview you
I'll buy the mid-level of your book that
you're launching meaning the mid-level
when they bundle them 50 books or
something
so it's kind of a stretch for us might
have been like a grand,
1500 but I was like okay we'd have less
influence we could then use these books
to do a giveaway
what does it do and and not so just
growth hacking your way up um and then
someone says okay cool that was good you
know and chop it up and clips
so anyways great idea but when someone
is launching a book that's when they're
on their PR tour and if if you just
pitch them a 30 minute thing and hey I'm
gonna give 10 copies of your book away
to our audience and we're going to
select them in the comments and so they
know they're going to do they know
they're going to sell 10 books
whether or not your episode gets
views
and they feel the honor and and you may
you don't say an hour you don't say and
if so if I could have five hours of your
time for a deep dive convers you know
what I mean like you might say you know
could you do a 25 minute so like just
hacking your way up realizing Henry
Cloud just wrote the business and
marriage thing you guys get to interview
him like whoever and you have other
people that you want and then a
willingness to follow up consistently
and a dream 50 to 100 list meaning a
hundred different names you reach out to
all of them with the size of your
Channel right now five say yes it's like
guaranteed eventually like if you are
just kind of consistent in communication
because they're all kind of and again
you're not going to get you know Dr Phil
uh yet um but but you certainly could
get somebody that they might share at
their Community tab one at a time
hand-to-hand social media combat we call
it like guerilla marketing in social
media yeah one to one one View at a time
one subscriber at a time time um and so
if you interview somebody and not to
classify but I think we can all
respectfully understand that there is
like aist b list and cist influence so
cist person's like sure I love it oh you
GNA buy 10 books great you're like
awesome you great interview and they're
like I'll share it you know on my
community tab as well they have their
own YouTube channel they share it on
social and it leads to like seven people
or like your podcast is so cool that's
how you build a community one person at
a time I think I heard an expert
recently tell me too he said all I'm
trying to do is reach two people a day
and he talked about the law of like
multiplication oh he was like I was
trying to reach two people a day that
would tell two people right exponential
growth and he was like do you know where
I'll be in a couple years I don't know I
don't even know what calculator that
would be called but he was like I'd have
250,000 listeners in like 36 months and
I was like huh if you reach two people a
day that would tell two people because
of the Excellence of your content the
value that it give the clarity knowing
your audience if two business bus owners
that have a family discovered you a day
and they told two other friends that hey
man you know how like we never found
anybody that has like a podcast just for
business and family this thing's pretty
good you should check it out check out
this interview that he just did with you
know this author it's a pretty good
episode and and that's 250,000 in 24
months or whatever the math is and so if
it's less than that and it's only 50,000
you know how what a viable business and
then Mission and impact that would be
meaning even if it wasn't two people a
day like it was more like one and a half
or only a half or you know so okay we've
we've said a lot Jason you thank you so
much feel like it was worth your time
jumping on today it was worth my time
Sean I appreciate it and I love V the
coaching the courses the accountability
so a plug for V Elite you know if anyone
is thinking about getting in there our
despite our Channel still being small we
have made a lot of changes and
implemented things because of the VRA
stuff so thank you so much J Jason so
grateful for you love what you're doing
and I think I hope that this was even a
god conversation you know like just like
a right thing right time getting ready
for 2024 really believing in what you're
doing and so uh keep building appreciate
it thank you all right take
care okay friends we got some Q&A I
didn't know we were going to go that
long telling hold stories and narratives
I hope there was some lessons I do want
to ask you for the 98 of us that are
hanging out would you consider hitting
the like button secondly
would you consider taking a time to
share an aha moment and unlock today we'
like to
get ahas and unlocks I got a Super Chat
that I'm gon to shout out thank you for
your
patience um but what was an aha moment
what did you like best what do you need
to do next what's one of your
commitments for December what are you
planning on 2024 what's your what's a
goal for 2024 I'd love to hear from you
let's hit the Super
Chat heyo Hammer the artist I can never
thank you enough for all the free
knowledge you provide thanks a million
Sean can't say gotta go okay so you're
probably not even seen this but thank
you for the $20 Super Chat really means
the world I hope these shows are helpful
and maybe help you think a little bit
different hope that you get value out of
them uh what are your YouTube
goals for
2024 uh yeah would you consider hitting
the like button that's all I ask not
going to charge you
anything um this was a this was a pretty
deep episode definitely never had this
combo before we talked about some deeper
business stuff um refresh and whatnot
we've linked up in the description like
five books if you're if you're thinking
about like really getting a business
mindset how I built this next five moves
crucial
conversations the other ones YouTube
secret second
edition um let's hit some of your
questions and before we do that let me
know no have you taken advantage of the
think media sale yet check out our
cyberweek sale that's
happening one of the there's two smart
things content creators should be
doing in December number one's posting
videos number two leveling up and
learning and preparing for
2024 May you're out walking walking the
dog hitting the gym working off those
holiday party calories you know whatever
put in some earbuds
go through the YouTube starter kit go
through YouTube Niche Finder this is
five courses for $57 but by the way this
pricing is super limited so if you want
to pack uh the complete package for
growing a successful YouTube channel in
2024 it's available right now at think
Medias
sale.com let me know have you taken any
of those programs have you had any
learnings have you picked up the sale
yet think media
sale.com and uh my aha moment is
planning on the business side side while
charging forward with posting it's great
glad I was grateful personal NBA is a
great book from what I've read so far I
I've heard about that one it's on my
shelf back here I've never read it so it
has not helped me very much but I agree
my friend Tim recommended that one so
that's a good one Gorilla Marketing yeah
I'm going to use that two contacts a day
and ask them to share that with two
others man the law of like what small
and big numbers and multiplication some
people sharing their goals hit 100K on
December 2024 this is the coffee with c
think media podcast Community hey who
could you share this with share this
with two people um I mean it but like uh
yeah do you know somebody that's
thinking about starting a YouTube
channel do you know somebody who's like
oh yeah I know a friend who's thinking
about starting a business or a side
project or a partnership with somebody
send them this link be like hey Midway
in this 90 minute you know video is a a
conversation that you might find
valuable because we we want to spread
knowledge that could just help people
you know reach their goals all right
lightning round on some Q&A as we land
the plane what are your thoughts on you
already answered that one before you use
a brand name should it be trademarked
Robin I don't know I mean number
one
sometimes things can't be trademarked or
they're difficult to
trademark um so you really got to to to
talk to a trademark attorney ultimately
number two there's a huge Spectrum here
a spectrum of like move fast get busy
take action and then a spectrum of
like you know talk to a trademark
attorney set up a
corporation and and number one there's
not necessarily the finances for that
but number two people that go to this
extreme never do anything until I get my
business right my my business card right
my website right until I get my
trademark never end up doing anything
but it does have to do with like the
scope and scale of your vision there's
things like like a book title can't be
copywritten can a YouTube channel you
know there's like a lot of think Medias
on
YouTube I
mean I don't
care I don't know maybe I should care
there's all there's also other think
Medias in other states but we do
different things so listen did you know
about the filter feature if you type in
think media go to filters you can look
at
when's the upload date is it under four
minutes or over 20 minutes all this
different stuff but you can also search
by channel so there's think media
there's think media podcast there's this
think
media there's creative minds think media
there's this think media there's this
think media there's this think media you
see how many think Medias there are on
YouTube there's like 40 on this page is
this think media has got two subscribers
holy think Medias think media expert
think we how long can we think media
to uh think media plus that's better
than than our think media because this
is the plus
version um think media da ISAC how long
think media another think media plus
think media entertainment think media to
Mill
wow uh this also is just like a side
quest that I haven't taken in a while
and it's just massively humorous to me
this wild
and um I mean so anyways I guess a
couple
things I am giving you no legal advice
uh
Robin Michael think media who stole our
logo great I I think media okay so I'm
not giving you Le another channel that
stole our logo another channel that
stole our
picture um there was there 700 think
Medias like how long can we think Media
news 360 which by the way that's like a
different name really these other ones
aren't though think media and
digital I'm so distracted because I'm
just wondering like think media Africa
with our logo and they have 10,000
subscribers what are we talking about
this is an entirely okay I just wondered
if they stole our content channels do we
get the copyright strike so you know um
that's cool uh let's see so how far I
this is this going to be scroll there's
may be an endless number of think Medias
in the world so what conclusion do we
have well I'm going to tell you this
Robin I am
personally
not going after any of those people or
like worried about that or like worried
about tracking them down I and the
reason this is not legal advice is I'm
not saying if some if you named yourself
compared to a different company or
something else or somebody else's brand
maybe that would you know they would I
guess I'm just too focused and too
confident in like we're just going to
build our thing and look at the numbers
and like we can rank our own videos and
people can do whatever they want by the
way you know how many YouTube Secrets
books there are and that's a little bit
different because you
can't sorry I gotta get to these q&as
but I hope y'all are having as much fun
as I'm having because this is just such
a funny okay there's YouTube Secrets
hacks for beginners there's two in ones
better than ours YouTube Secrets two
books in one there's YouTube Insider
Secrets there's YouTube Secrets
literally the same name there's YouTube
secrets and veiled there's YouTube
Secrets there's YouTube growth hacks
similar kind of there's
uh uh YouTube marketing secrets and so
and there's more than this we screenshot
them all the time all kinds of weird
little niche ones but but here'd be my
ethic on even that like the reason it
doesn't make me even insecure nor do I
worry about following up and again you
can't copyright a book title but I'm
like a 45 page ebook with a janky cover
is not threatening a really well-written
properly published book and a YouTube
channel with somebody who's not
consistent who just put your name and
has two subscribers is not worth
comparing to somebody who's putting in
high effort patience and and and really
building their brand I'm open to your
opinions too let me know your thoughts
on on all of the above
so I'm not even actually maybe giving
you a final clusion I'm saying what's
your vision I think maybe most people
overthink it I think a wise startup
entrepreneur maybe really does think
about a trademark and are you g to build
a software what are you g to build what
brand are you g to build how long are
you committed to it
but my non-legal advice
is
I I would think about it day one but I
think most content creators it might not
be the something that you need to think
about day one it's up to you what would
your advice be to someone trying to
break into the you
philanthropy philanthropy space I don't
know what that
means um but my advice if I think I know
what it
means
is what value does the channel
add nonprofits struggle because they
don't create a value based Channel
offering like here's how I think
nonprofits the way that nonprofit
profits should approach YouTube is not
just putting up a
portfolio of their content and their
donor video and a recap video of the
recent thing they did and a story about
somebody and a testimonial if I have a
nonprofit that I that I want to grow
what I would do is I would probably
start a video podcast that is targeted
at my target donor demographic that
might be unrelated to my nonprofit but
it would be a value based video video
podcast that grows an audience and the
entire video podcast would be sponsored
by the nonprofit and would be kind of I
would use the awareness of it so like
maybe what I would do is I would create
like a Christian Business Leaders video
podcast and then I would add a ton of
value in interview guest and then I
would say hey if you want to make a
difference and you want to whatever this
is this nonprofit over here because I
think the best way to Market is with
actual value value to the end user and
something that and rather than just like
we need money at the end of the year and
donors or whatever it is like
philanthropy it's
actually there's a reason to watch your
content all year long so what content
could you create that's not just oh you
uploaded a new like mission video recap
or something but like oh it's a weekly
show that I listen to so I'm constantly
aware of this and my year-end giving or
whatever would go to you kind of a
different approach so I think that's an
interesting thought my algorithm seems
to prefer shorts how could I divert to
long form besides thumbnail and title
well Nicholas add on the next one and
say it isn't just thumbnail and title
it's going to be topic thumbnail and
title for your click-through rate but
it's going to be average view duration
and your audience retention curve for
the video popping off so how can you
divert to more long form better editing
better communication better structure in
the video be brief be bright be fun be
done perfect video recipe we teach
inside of
v um don't like write off like oh my
content like long form isn't performing
that's going to be the secret of long
form is going to be editing and all of
that kind of stuff and and good quality
content watchtime friends Sean do you
have any advice for new reaction Channel
I would ask about analytics but most of
my info says not enough data can the
channel utilize affiliate
marketing um the question to ask my
friend is what is the intent of the
viewer
so if you reacted
to a new commercial
for and this is probably not what you do
but if you reacted to Sony's
a6700 commercial I've done this before
they they dropped the I think the Canon
M50 Mark I trailer from Canon in
Australia so I reacted to it well I can
do that is logical to have an affiliate
link to that because it's about a
product if you're reacting to something
that's Entertainment based and you're
like forcing or just like trying to do
affiliate links the reason the person's
watching the video is not based on
affiliate links but if you reacted to a
fashion video and then link to a store
that sells those hoodies and people so
you just have to think about like there
actually being a connection and it being
logical you can't it's intent why is the
person watching it why is the person
watching a product review
perhaps because they want to make a
purchase why is a person person watching
a political uh commentary on on what's
happening in in in the country in
politics they probably don't want to
make a purchase now in inserted in those
videos might be like hey support the
channel support the mission join our
patreon um so you might be able to
insert a commercial quote unquote if you
get a lot of views but that's still only
going to be
awareness you know my friend JP Sears
who's a conser a
comedian
uh does really funny skits and at the
end of everyone he's like here's the
brand deal and it actually has nothing
to do with the skit like but he got your
attention to your point because that
maybe the video is really funny and the
reaction video was funny so at the end
you could be like hey and so then do you
even want to do affiliate Market hey but
before you
go if you are looking
for an awesome monthly subscription box
for if you're looking for if hey before
you go cyber security matters use the
link in the description to get a you
know a six months of nordvpn and sign up
as an affiliate so in that case it's
just like make great content get a lot
of views you don't even actually need to
have a brand sponsorship give a shout
out to a SAS that's Universal enough
because if you're like broad
entertainment and like whether it's your
phone whether you're traveling in the
holidays at the airport whether um you
just want to log in to uh watch Netflix
use the VPN feature to get all the
different movies you don't get in
America because using the VPN you can
get the Europe movies by like tricking
Netflix it's up to you if you want to
promote that
um that could be an affiliate call to
action at the end of your entertainment
or whatever it is and
then let's leave it there we so we I
hope that add a little value and then
finally Robin have you do you have any
intellectual property lawyers on
regardless what do you recommend if
someone else trades Mark a business name
you've been using uh well before they
trademarked it I mean again Robin I'm no
legal advice but you might look at like
the history of the company the trademark
2 is interesting because think media we
looked at it like some are like an
agency and we're not an agency there's
different states could you be the thing
in a state could you be the thing in a
country there's also how complex it is
think media is too like meaningless it's
like very short and we've been down this
road a couple of times
um but also we look at how big how many
subscribers how old is it how old is
their thing and so on and so forth if
somebody else gets the trademark what is
that trademark mean will they enforce
the trademark intellectual property is
another one it's very hard to enforce
what are you g to do follow up with you
know by the way people like spinning off
bootleg versions of YouTube secrets in
other countries and stuff what am I
gonna do like I'm mad get on the plane
like which you might want to do that but
I think so I I'm not trying to put any
negative shade on the questions I'm just
trying to give you my honest answers and
how I think about it like I want to
choose winnable battles and guard my
energy and think about where I invest
all of the
above is information is just so
stealable and so spin-off and so and
then the thing is the people who steal
the
information what would happen if you sue
them do they have any money good
questions to ask would would it be worth
following up on that I don't know maybe
it would be
so so okay there's two extremes
one ignore this have massive success and
then really regret because you had like
you had so much success that you would
have wish you got things in place and
then again the other extreme it's
another way of saying what I said
earlier get so obsessed with this that
you never go you never get super focused
and go create massive
success kind of a More Money Mo Problems
sometimes we're maybe a like we're so
we're we're we're trying to manage
something that's not even a problem
unless it actually blows up to a big
enough level um and once it blows up to
a level you have the problems and so you
could always you think this is you could
have things like insur things like
insurance by the way there's
insurances for like theft of
intellectual property it's another way
to approach it so you maybe see these
and you look at damages and the person
so it is it it's a pretty big and and
yeah we've we've done a lot of all the
above and we continuously do it but
we're always weighing kind of like how
much red tape how much stuff we want to
get in what is it is it a battle worth F
fighting and these are some great the
really good questions is it a battle
worth fighting is it a rabbit worth
chasing and is even if the battle was
like worth fighting is the battle even
winnable because why would you go into a
battle that you can't win have you
studied the case study on what happened
do you think you're going to do the same
thing are you going to build up the
intellectual property of Zig Ziggler or
Jim ran and you might be like yeah I'm
almost there okay cool so like so it's
even thinking through some things um and
and more than anything I hope that that
adds value to you um and just gives you
more questions to ask in some things all
right let me hit this one other Super
Chat is it better to end suddenly or say
my video ending it's probably better to
end suddenly number one or number two
end quickly and number
three end boringly and not quickly would
be the
worst so you could just end it's great
because it really could get watch time
to the end you also could end you have
up to 20 seconds to do an end card so
what you could do is is sort of trans we
teach the transition so you sort of like
as you're concluding your video you
immediately point to the next video so
you're like you know and listen if if
you want to actually learn how to do
that click or tap the screen to watch
another video smash like if you got
value out of this video my name is Sean
canel RS with YouTube channel I'll see
you in the next one so you could have
about an seven second transition maybe a
sixc 8C transition it's great and
suddenly keep it brief if you're going
to do a transition um definitely I would
say avoid all right guys so thanks so
much for checking out the
video you know grateful and maybe we'll
see each other again maybe we will maybe
we won't but I hope you've enjoyed
yourself when I switch to this camera
angle it looks like the frame rate's off
but it's just because my ATM like is
overheating or something so if I switch
back over here it's a little bit
smoother um anyways you know so I think
that uh I hope those tips helped my
friends it is 11:55 a. Pacific Standard
Time on December 1st 2023 if you're
watching on the replay hasht replay
famam if you made it to the end
hashtag
made it to the end if
you made it to the end on the replay
you're a legend and I'm sending you love
and respect uh I hope you're H I'll see
you before the holidays before Christmas
and stuff and we'll have some more cop
for you with Chanel so subscribe hit
like this is not a good outro by the way
right this is a longer outro because
we're in a two-hour live stream and
we're hanging out with the homies um and
so but I do hope you're having a great
December welcome to new month if you're
just joining I would encourage you to
watch the first 10 minutes of this video
because it's about getting your mind
right your goals set your focus fixed
I'm maximizing December and January it's
a strategic time to go all in on YouTube
and if you're looking for something to
do next your your your next best move is
to text your mom and say I love you
you'll thank me later for that one
equally and probably more important than
that is to text your partner your spouse
and sayi love you I'm thinking about you
and you mean a lot to me you thank me
for that one uh your next best move
after number three is to go to think
Medias sale.com and get our cyberweek
sale and watch the whole thing in
December let's make 2024 your best year
and I want you to join me for the
YouTube road map Workshop this GNA be a
4-Hour event it's happening in January
privately um it's it's a whole strategic
annual planning YouTube strategy session
it's an online virtual event you get a
ticket included in this you get five
courses for
$57 you know later on tonight this
weekend you could go to Red Robin That's
how much your bill is going to cost and
you're going by yourself that's a lot at
Red Robin I mean how did you spend that
much um you know you're GNA go out you
be like honey let's uh let's just make
something out of the covers why because
I bought the cyber cyber week sale oh
cool how much $57 well that's great we
would have spent $100 on dinner like
there's so many ways it's just a
no-brainer right and and uh I'm not
trying to just pitch something I am
shocked by like how much we've included
five courses for $57 that's the point is
it's a radical deal um and it's not just
some random information this is deeply
strategic PDF downloads a ticket to next
year's event AI for YouTube starter kit
just the clarity of blueprint alone I'm
convinced that you will thank me later
when you see how valuable this is and
all of that is available at think Medias
sal.com
uh my name is Sean canel and it does
rhyme with YouTube channel sending you
love and respect gratitude hope you have
a great rest of the day great weekend we
will talk soon on a future episode and
until then keep crushing it keep
smashing it peace